Is walking 10,000 steps a day really the ultimate
way to reach good health?
Anthony Carboni here for DNews and about a
year ago I heard that walking 10,000 steps
a day is better for you than just about anything
else you can do.
Why?
Well, the average person has such a sedentary
lifestyle- sitting at a desk, in the car,
in front of the TV or computer- that doing
the recommended 30 minutes of moderate physical
activity recommended by the CDC couldn't possibly
counteract all that lying around.
But why 10,000 steps?
What's the theory behind it?
What research led to this magical, seemingly
way-too-round and simple a number?
Well, none.
At first.
In the 1960s, walking clubs were super popular
in Japan.
So popular that everyone wanted pedometers.
Those pedometers were marketed under the name
"manpo-kei," which means "10,000 steps meter,"
because Japanese doctor Yoshiro Hatano estimated
that should be enough to burn 20% of the calories
someone takes in.
Good name.
Good estimate.
The concept stuck.
But does walking 10,000 steps a day actually
work?
Yes- studies done recently show that hitting
the goal can lower your blood pressure and
improve your glucose levels.
An Australian study showed that meeting the
goal actually improved their brain function
and level of physical fitness by 2 percent-
but so can considerably less, for most people.
The average American takes about 5,100 steps
a day.
The CDC says that upping that to 8,000 can
still give you the health benefits you need-
and is basically equivalent to adding a 30
minute walk onto your day.
Soooo... what if you already work out?
Or jog- even if you get less than 10,000 steps,
running's gotta be equal to walking, right?
Not really.
Over the last 19 years, obesity in the US
has increased about 57%- and physical activity
at work and at home has declined at a similar
rate.
We sit around a LOT.
Laci did an entire video here on the channel
about how unhealthy long periods of sitting
can be.
So if you jog a couple miles and get 4000
steps in, or hit the gym and get 30 minutes
of increased heartrate, but spend the other
23 and a half hours of your day sitting around,
you're not getting the same health benefits
you would by hitting the gym but ALSO making
sure you hit your goal.
That's not to say stop going to the gym.
It's also not to say jump in now and get 8,000
to 10,000 steps a day RIGHT AWAY.
Adding any level of activity can get you immediate
benefits.
Colorado has one of the lower obesity rates
in the US, and they walk about 6,500 steps
a day.
Tennesee and Arkansas have high obesity rates,
and they walk 4,500 steps a day.
That 2,000 steps makes a big difference.
So no- 10,000 steps is not a magic number,
and it's not going to get you in shape on
its own.
But a day full of slow, steady, simple physical
activity like walking can be extremely healthy
for you.
Have you guys tried this?
How's it working for you?